all of our helmet technology is coming
out of this facility so our designers
will start off probably it's sketches so
then we have a design idea and they may
walk through a bunch of different
iterations sketches and then once a
design direction is is kind of laid out
picked then we move into again the
ideation phase so this may be what the
designer has in mind all right off the
bat so helmet may start off being you
know very Airy a lot of big deep
channels and inventing but knowing from
the testing we have to making changes
this helmet was interesting because it
was born out of more function we had a
definite goal for this helmet to create
a narrow road so we had to try to keep a
real smooth shape so you see icon on
call screen here that's that's where the
function go for one so you wouldn't
necessarily wear this helmet if you're
going slower you're climbing but any of
the sprinting stages relatively flat
stages this we believe is the perfect
helmets today so we run the helmet
through a series of tests in multiple
locations on the helmet and we have to
be under a certain G threshold so that
how much would be acceptable depending
on the country we're selling it into
so UT kind of this this rolling
progression of aerodynamics lightweight
vented then back to aerodynamics again
what can we learn so you're this
constant iteration of tweaking parts of
the design and all culminating into a
helmet that we really feel needs what
the right of looking for
you